>> Laura: IT IS TIME FOR
EXCITEMENT WHEN WE EXPOSE THE
BIG CULTURAL STORIES.
TONIGHT'S FOCUS, LEADS ARE
GETTING YOU IN AMERICA, THE
BOYCOTT AND TWO STATES DON'T
WANT YOU TO EAT AT CHICK-FIL-A.
JOINING US NOW, THE FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR IN
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" BEST SELLE
BEST SELLER.
WHY ARE THE HOLLYWOOD DO-GOODER
ELITES NOW TRYING TO MESS WITH
THE GEORGIANS?
>> GEORGIA IS POISED TO PASS
WHAT THEY CALL THE HEART BILL.
THE ACTRESS WHO IS SHOOTING A
NETFLIX SERIES HAS GOTTEN 100
ACTORS TO SIGN A LETTER
THREATENING TO BOYCOTT THE STATE
IF IT PASSES THE HEARTBEAT LAW.
THEY INCLUDE ALEC BALDWIN, AMY
SCHUMER AND OTHERS.
SHE EVEN HELD A PRESS OR THE
GEORGIA STATE HOUSE WITH 30
COWORKERS.
MARCH.
>> WE WOULD LIKE TO REMIND YOU
THAT GOVERNMENT IS NEVER BEGGAR
AND WHEN IT IS INSIDE A WOMAN'S
BODY OR INSIDE HER DOCTOR'S
OFFICE.
>> I'VE NEVER SEEN A GOVERNMENT
IN A WOMAN'S BODY.
>> Laura: DOES SHE HAVE A
HEARTBEAT?
>> SHE TRIED TO DELIVER THAT TO
THE GOVERNOR.
>> Laura: WHAT IS SHE WEARING
ON HER HEAD?
>> WATCHED.
>> I WORK IN GEORGIA.
>> TO LIVE IN GEORGIA?
WHAT DISTRICT ARE YOU FROM?
>> DON'T INTERRUPT ME.
>> Laura: DON'T INTERRUPT ME.
THE CONGRESSMAN ASKED THE RIGHT
QUESTION GREAT WHAT STATE ARE
YOU FROM?
THE STATE OF GEORGIA DELIVERS
$3 MILLION AND THIS IS THE
THANKS THEY GET.
BULLYING FROM THE VERY PEOPLE
WHO BENEFIT FROM THEIR
GENEROSITY.
THE GOVERNMENT OF GEORGIA HAS
NEVER DONE A COST BENEFIT
ANALYSIS FOR THE $300 MILLION TO
GIVE AWAY TO HOLLYWOOD.
THEY MIGHT FIND THEY'RE NOT
MAKING AS MUCH.
>> Laura: WHAT WOULD THEY DO
GEORGIA WITHOUT HIM AROUND?
WAS THE BOSS?
IT IS TRUMP.
>> AND ANOTHER ACT OF SOUTHERN
HARASSMENT, THE ANCHOR READ AN
ARTICLE IN A LOCAL MISSISSIPPI
NEWSPAPER AND TOLD THE STORY OF
A HUNTER WHO TRACKED AND KILLED
A RARE WHITE TURKEY.
IT WAS SO ENRAGED THAT HE
TWEETED, THE RARE AND BEAUTIFUL,
THIS PEA BRAIN SCUMBAG AND WE
SHOULD DO ALL OUR BEST TO MAKE
SURE THE REST OF HIS LIFE IS A
LIVING AND THE CLOWN WHO WROTE
THIS SHOULD BE FIRED.
HOW DOES HE THINK SLICED TURKEY
GETS THERE?
DOES IT SLEIGHTS ITSELF OF THE
WILD?
HE HAD TO APOLOGIZE AND HE IS
OFFICIALLY THE WORST PERSON IN
THE WORLD!
>> Laura: IN THE WORLD
ACTUALLY.
THESE ELITES ARE GETTING IN
TRYING TO TELL US WHAT WE CAN
AND CANNOT EAT.
OF COURSE THEY ARE NOT HAPPY AND
THEY ALWAYS WANT GOVERNMENT OUT
OF A WOMAN'S BODY BUT THEY WANT
TO AFFECT GOES AND HER BODY.
CHICK-FIL-A HAS BEEN BARRED AT
TWO AIRPORTS, BUFFALO AND
SAN ANTONIO.
THIS IS BECAUSE OF THE
COMPLAINTS ALLEGED AGAINST THE
COMPANY'S STANCE ON LGBT ISSUES.
>> THIS IS ABOUT MAKING PUBLIC
SPACES AVAILABLE TO EVERYBODY.
>> I DON'T THINK IT WOULD BE
ENOUGH FOR ME TO PREVENT A
CHICK-FIL-A.
I LIKE THEIR FOOD.
>> IT IS ONE THING IF CONSUMERS
WANT TO DECIDE THAT NOT GOING TO
THAT RESTAURANT BECAUSE OF THE
POLITICAL VIEWPOINT.
I GUESS WE WILL POST IT LIKE
CALORIE COUNT.
FOR THE GOVERNMENT TO BAN A
RESTAURANT SEEMS WAY OVER THE
TOP.
>> THIS IS THE BEGINNING.
>> Laura: IT NOW WE WILL ONLY
HAVE CERTAIN RESTAURANTS FOR
CONSERVATIVES I GUESS.
THAT IS HOW THEY WANT TO PLAY?
>> I HAVE TO SHARE THIS WITH
EVERYONE.
THIS IS A PICTURE, I WATCHED
THIS TAKING PLACE.
THIS IS YOU AND JOE BIDEN AT A
PARTY MANY YEARS AGO.
I THOUGHT ABOUT THIS.
DO YOU REMEMBER HE WALKED UP TO
YOU AND PUT BOTH OF HIS HANDS ON
HER SHOULDERS AND SAID HONEST TO
GOD, OF ALL THE RIGHT-WINGERS,
YOU'RE MY FAVORITE.
WATCH THIS.
IT WAS TO BUILD YOU UP.
>> I'VE ALWAYS TRIED TO MAKE A
UNION CONNECTION, SHAKE HANDS
AND HUG PEOPLE I GRABBED MEN AND
WOMEN BY THE SHOULDERS.
>> YOU'RE MY FAVORITE HOST.